hey guys welcome back and I hope they're
having a great Sunday and you might be
noticing something different and yeah
I'm actually not playing Ken today for
once today I decided to give Ken's a
little break I've been going to good
with him he's good I'm not dropping him
he's just kind of getting bored so I
started picking up a new mane
I started flying the bushi a bit I've
ever I've been ranking her up a bit and
I'm still not the greatest as you could
probably tell by this gameplay but then
II you know boo she mains got any ideas
I'm all ears because this character is a
bit difficult for me to comprehend them
how to use but that's not the topic of
today's video topic of today's video is
about some of the posts that have been
happening on reddit a few things about a
max level glitch players not receiving
awards and such so let's get into that
so apparently people still haven't
gotten their compensation gift yet if
you remember from yesterday's video or
the last video I mentioned how players
who played during June 17th and June
19th may have encountered a bug where
players wouldn't receive rewards after
matches such as myself you be self
during the devastated states that all
players affected by this which would get
their compensation melee pack which
contains three days of champion status
in a premium-grade according to some
players though on reddit they haven't
been able they haven't even gotten their
their crates yet and many of their gifts
these were supposed to be given out
three days ago so why are players still
not getting them me personally I don't
know if I have been or not I do believe
I have because I have had champion
status since the beginning of season two
because it does stack with season pass
and as for the crate I don't really pay
attention to those but I do believe I
have received mine
other players have not this does kind of
suck though so let's hope they can get
this fixed and get all their players
they their generous rewards the next
post today which I'm going to be showing
you is a guard brick a guard break
flicker bug holy [ __ ] I can't say that
we're in the clip I know boo she was
facing allah bringer and then the LA
bringer would faint his guard break and
then do a light attack or a heavy attack
and then oh boo she couldn't defend
because it's just common instinct that
when someone guard breaks you you
counter back or you're going to get hit
with some heavy damage but since she
tried to go for the guard break the wall
bringer countered or fainted the guard
break and then basically used a light
attack or a heavy attack
attacker and that seemed to happen
throughout the whole match this is
called soft fainting it worked it also
works with light attacks as well but you
be self noticed the patch immediately
and passed it out but it seems to even
either come back when they screw it up
during coding or it was introduced back
in the game again by just by complete
accident or they pet word they never
even patched it but nonetheless it's
still in the game for the few people of
you actually asking how to do this I
don't know how to do this at all no but
I want to this is kind of a this is kind
of a game breaker because you are
fainting a guard break which doesn't
make any sense to me so I wouldn't tell
you anyway and I don't know how to do it
myself
so we'll just leave it at that but
hopefully this can get fixed or
something because as you can tell by
this clip this no boo she got manhandled
absolutely no chance against the wall
bringer at all it was just completely
gone it was completely settled by the
completely end of the game and then the
last bit of news I have for you is
people have been kind of posting this
quite often surprisingly as a lot of
their characters are leveling up and
instead of getting the next rank they
get the max to rank text in the middle
where the circle is now technically
whenever you reach like let's say you
reach level 9 you rank up you see a
level 10 well some players when they try
to finish their rep level instead of
going to level 20 to rep one they'll get
just max rank and then they can't go any
higher such as this no bushi but I
thought okay well it's only one person
hopefully it's not too bad but then I
found out that this nobu she isn't the
only player there was a warden and then
there was a Centurion and there was
another Centurion there was three
Centurions that experienced this on
reddit and the warden I told you about
before and then there was even a warlord
that experiences I couldn't find the
photo but you have to take my word for
that now luckily this patch or this
glitch isn't too bad the only fix to
this though is just resetting your game
after the match quit turn off the game
take it out put it back in everything
should be back to normal
although it is kind of it is kind of
annoying and it does probably scare you
a bit when you first see it it still
shouldn't be that way it should
definitely be brought up in the dead
stream because glitches like this really
shouldn't happen I don't know about you
guys but if I had that I'd
we have a heart attack immediately
because then you can't go any higher on
your rep level at all anyway guys it's
going to be the video for today like the
video if you did enjoy dislike it if you
didn't if you're new subscribe to hit
the bell so you could be part of the
notification squad and then never miss
one of my videos you cannot you can also
click the annotation on the top right to
be taken to my previous video where we
talked about upcoming patches and
features to the game that are coming
soon you don't want to miss that and I
will see you all later guys peace out
and have a great rest of your Sunday